matt baume's 7-9 this year he's made 21
starts 4-3-7 era pretty good whip of a
1.17
fastball cutter curveball slider and a
change he's got a lot of pitches most of
them all breaking balls only throws his
fastball 36 percent of the time here at
chase field he's 4-3 with a 3-9-0 era
and jp lines one right field in and out
of the glove of the right fielder josh
rojas
jp the last few games mike had some good
abs stinging the ball now he's hitting
the ball hard and this is another line
drive off the bat good start for the
mariners and for jp crawford solid line
drive hooking away from the outfielder
swinging the ground ball up the middle
by hanniger and it's in a center field
for a base hit so henniger with a single
to center that's going to get crawford
to second base and right away the
mariners have a chance to get to
bumgarner early in the ball game bomb
garner ready and delivers the 02 and a
swing of the miss
he gets france on strikes one down he
got him to chase boy it was a nice pitch
a backdoor cutter just off the plate
away now the mariners have the bases
loaded with two outs here in the top of
the first inning for catcher tom murphy
runners take off pitch the murph inside
ball four runs scores one-nothing
mariners rbi for thomas 26th average
sitting at 153.
he swings and he hits one to right
rojos has got a beat on it though in
right field and he makes the catch and
that'll end the inning they get a run
two hits in the inning to hit bad or a
walk they leave them loaded
lefty out there as well for seattle
tyler anderson who pitched for the
pirates here at chase field on july 20th
that turned out to be his final start
with pittsburgh he was traded to the
mariners a week later now here he is
again now anderson ready the wind up and
the one-two pitch swing and a miss for
strike three so tyler strikes out the
first battery that he faces nick ahmed
and again the 1-2 to kelly swing and a
miss and he got one by him for strike
three and that's going to retire the
side a couple of strikeouts for tyler
anderson tyler anderson taking care of
the diamondbacks one two three with a
couple of strikeouts in the bottom of
the first inning now he takes a look at
first baseman christian walker
good to go
and they check with alex tosin said he
did three strikeouts in the first four
men that he's faced nice start for tyler
anderson the wind-up and the 1-2 on the
way to rojas swung on and a fly ball
into right center field going back
hanniga on the run near the woody track
and he's there to make the catch and
that's going to retire the side six in a
row
set down by tyler anderson we go to the
top of the third from chase field in
phoenix it's the mariners one and the
diamondbacks nothing well mitch hanniger
stands in an o1 count bumgarner the
veteran lefty nods his head up and down
ready to go into his motion here it
comes to mitch
swung on hard ground ball diving making
the stop is young the second baseman
throwing a first on a hop not in time
mitch henniger beats it out he has an
infield base hit that's the second knock
for hanniger in the ball game the
mariners back in business here with
runners at first and second and one out
fly ball into center
sending marty back he'll get it
and there's a catch france goes back
late doesn't attempt to tag in advance
and that's not number two on the inning
the swinging strike three has murphy
down on strikes
third for bumgarner it's been six up six
down for tyler anderson the left he's
been sharp here comes the one two
swinging a miss got him another punch
out that is strikeout number four
as anderson has retired the first seven
he has seen he's been awfully good so
far seven up seven down puts it in the
glove his 2-2 pitch to bumgarner
swung on hit high deep to right field
but playable henniger right there in
front of the track reaches up makes a
one-hand catch
and tyler anderson has been outstanding
so far nine up nine down in order it's
the mariners one and the diamondbacks
nothing tyler anderson has retired the
first nine batters his face with four
strikeouts along the way and now we'll
take a look again at the top of the
order nick ahmed and ahmed swings and
hits it to center
backing up on it still going back still
going back and a nice botched drop by
kilnick and then he drops it again
ahmed's head for third base here's the
throw and he slides in safely
now dives got a break looked like
kelnick covered a lot of ground
out there in center but then dropped the
ball then couldn't find it right away
one out runner at third carson kelly the
hitter he struck out on a one-two pitch
and a line drive left field that'll tie
the ball game at bay set kelly a one-out
single to play to ahmed and this game is
tied to one anderson kicks and he
delivers swaying in a pop-up
into left-center field over calling for
dylan moore now celtic takes over
kelnick wants it he makes the catch
that's going to retire the side errors
have to go ahead and run aboard mitch
haniger two for two base hit the center
and an infield hit
that's it well left field down the line
staying fair
bye-bye
two-run homer mitch haniger and for
mitch home run number 30 rbi 74 75 and
the mariners have a 3-1 lead
there's a
fly ball into right ross is there and
he's got it
side retired but the problem with the
first two hitters walk on the tour
mariners with the lead off man aboard as
jared kellnick will stand in he's over
two though he leaned on that one
that is crank giddy up gone
jk
gets one out a two-run shot and emeritus
have a 5-1 lead at arizona
tyler anderson has been very sharp in
this one for the mariners he's given up
just one run so far that came in the
fourth inning tell you what gary he has
been mr reliable ever since joining the
ball club here's the 2-0
swung on line drive right field racing
in here comes haniger makes a shoestring
catch on the move nice play
two away
six in a row put down by anderson now
set his 02 pitch
swung on hard ground ball up the middle
but right there in the shift is toro
behind the bag
throws to first in time seven in a row
put down by anderson he retires the side
in order tyler anderson there he is
pitching into the seventh for the second
time in fact in consecutive games and
walker skies one into right center field
nobody's gonna get that and that ball is
gonna go off the wall out there extra
bases christian pulls into second base
with a double the runner at second here
in the seventh and now the banner will
be andrew young
andrew young pokes one down the line and
that's a fair ball it's in the corner
and it's in the bullpen it's an rbi
double for andrew young and it's five to
two
change has been made anderson's night is
done he pitched well and sean doolittle
will come on for the mariners
knocks that one through right by second
base um ted barrett here comes andrew
young he will score and it's five to
three joshua hawks the rbi knock
nick base hit
rojas is home here comes fairchild the
throw is netted time and we're tied at
five
it's a four run seventh in a five five
ball game bases loaded two outs seventh
in it here comes the 3-2
swing and a miss it's paul seawall and
he's got him
and leaves the bases loaded a big
strikeout for paul seawall and we stayed
high
checks
and a fly ball to right
backing up on it is paving smith at the
wall and he caught it
out number two and the runner houses
back to first and he just did get in
haven went back to the wall the fence
out there and reached up and gloved it
handicra was on the move to sega down to
scurry back
and pavon made a pretty good throw back
but not in time quantizer popped up
should get him
van meter third baseman is under it and
he's got it beside retired delic looking
to be the hero here as he settles in
from the left side
swung on ripped into left field towards
the line it's getting down it is down a
fair ball rolling to the corner sega is
going to score and the murders have
taken the lead in extra innings it is
six to five m's
jared kelly coming through
johann ramirez the right-hander his
first pitch to walker
swung on lifted to the outfield
short right field racing in hanaker he's
there he's there he makes the catch and
the ball game is over
you